hey guys I'm Greg hey guys I'm Andrew
Andrew from the movie source channel and
egg or 7-eleven on Twitter and Instagram
we're going to be watching the iron fist
shelwyn come out I believe it comes out
in large 15 March 15 right around the
corner people to run around the corner
it's got requested just yesterday from a
few people first request I saw coming
Matt 778 as your visual little
acknowledgment bread hey hey what do we
have an idea
I don't know way you came from you're
welcome any sense when we sent me
Colleen she's been trying to survive
let's begin Colleen was in the dojo with
you yeah she looks at the kid
sighs are about trying to teach you how
to perform in the real world she
represents honor discipline self
discipline which she hides its edge I
loved you add another fighter and when I
went in double my fading you are one
crazy chick you know that Colin isn't a
lot of financial trouble she's in such
dire straits she ends up going to a
fight club you ready for the party
reward end up liking it oh yeah oh yeah
that is never seen women is strong in
his bid was called me I won't charge him
after he has to win her over I'm asking
you nicely to leave a fast initial
reaction is you're praising and then
when she sees how good of a fighter is
she starts to realize that's something
else about him
[Music]
you got an iron fit
[Music]
my interest
everything she's curious he's so
intriguing I need someone like anyone
who's ever met she was no kill you cuz
not gonna happen but she kind of take
her gambled weekend along good together
are the only persons with an open it's a
very traumatic relationship mysteries
such a big part of our show and then
element it was it fate was it meant to
be I think she knows it's danny's longer
perhaps but it's intoxicating I'm going
with here so do not
I mean with amazing people will know
what a great stone in figure [ __ ] I
insist is in a league of its own in the
show that keeps you on your toes
[Music]
okay okay all right well I got some
thoughts here I got some soft I'd like
to share with you Andrew and you guys to
just dawned on me that this actually
drop on international Woman's that makes
sense she's a strong feminine character
way to go women you women rock you're
all badass I can't help get Pat like
when I saw the couple of trailers for
iron fist I was like looks good looks
cool at the same time I had concerns I
concerned that this didn't look like it
had a very specific kind of flare so the
show didn't feel like it has something
unique about it you know like when I
think about the other shows on Netflix
from the Marvel Universe they're very
distinct and very specific and this kind
of just looked like a typical kind of I
don't know something that might get
canceled in the CW at some point I
forgot it would it look like them a
bunch of reviews have drop in the past
week and a lot of them are not very good
reviews and they're they're kind of
addressing a lot of their concerns
actually hack as I was like well every
trailer is seen for the marble shows
I've never been to wild I so I thought
that okay maybe it's just a trailer but
watching watching the footage here I
think this is one of the better trailers
or featurettes that we've gone from Iron
Fist this character does sound cool and
I'm actually like all right I'm a little
drawn more now to knowing more about the
other characters in the show that's
always a nice surprise when I watch
these shows is I tuned in for daredevil
then I end up loving all the other
characters I've tuned in for location
and loving all the other characters yeah
and she seems like a cool character get
on board would he use good Asian female
lead right now no I definitely agree i
mean you nailed it those other shows
they all have a distinct flavors I'm i
think what i love about this shows on
top of what you just said we love the
other characters they're villains are
just so yeah I'm admirable you got the
purple man in jessica jones wilson fisk
of course and daredevil and then
Kottonmouth in luke cage and Diamondback
but a more cotton out for me but just
again the villains are what set them
apart lake and obviously marvel is not
the most well known for their zones of
course the best when I'm looking forward
to because so far like the chemistry and
the hand-to-hand combat and some of the
stuff
seeing the progression we're seeing with
the characters where they're you know
where they're kind of lost a little bit
you know they're looking for something
more unique you know you see the
progression of the relationship building
like that's a hold of good and all but
I'm more curious to see like who the
zones going to be in this season and if
it's going to be on par with some of
those other villains because like I said
that's what you know sets though shows
apart for me it's like I'm so drawn in
not only by the main characters of
course but by their adversaries I really
feel like the stakes are always high
because I'm so in tune with what the
what's going on with the zones and i
love the villains in these shows well
what I heard from a couple of reviews is
that there's no real main villain here
and that the villain in it is the hand
of who we saw in daredevil season two
more okay that's one thing I heard the
show is lacking actually is like a
really distinct villain something that
really propels the show forward and adds
to the world and everything to me is
like from everything I've been hearing
it kind of feels like it's been going
down the Avengers face one tap iron man
2 setting up for a vendor's Lansing you
have like you have a big look at this
yet Iron Man Iron Man daredevil right
then you have jessica jones then you
have iron man 2 daredevil season 2 then
you have sores then you got Luke Cage
and then you have Captain America the
First Avenger and now you have iron fist
and then you get the Avengers and then
you're going to get the defenders and
the thing that I remember was the first
avenger that kind of was a bummer for me
was that it seemed like they were kind
of rushing through this really
interesting time period is this is a
specific parts and Captain America's
life so they can get to the Avengers and
what I've been hearing from the reviews
that because they release the first six
episodes to a lot of critics is it kind
of feels like they just sort of their
making iron fist to kind of hurry up and
get the defenders now I don't know this
because show could be good this is a
specific trailer for calling wing the
character seems all right the the action
sequences I haven't seen any clothes
from the action sequence of them like
they look this mission a little bit but
not too yeah they look okay they don't
look like they're rebel status i'm kind
of want that though for a show a martial
artist yeah I would love that to have
the daredevil caliber of fight
choreography but the action sequences
look kind of generic like television
generic action sequences tomato right
now yeah no I'm with you like daredevil
it man yeah no I mean the standard is
really high now when we're looking at
hand-to-hand combat and when we're
talking about a character as unique is
this like calling wing and you got Danny
ran like you're expecting like the Agra
I'm a hand hand combat to be around that
level oh I'm with you I hope I'm when
we're watching the show that it does not
feel you know like it's more like a TV
show you know more like that would be
suited for the CW network and nothing
against those shows this shows a fine
and their own unique style as well like
arrow and those shows and such but again
when we watch daredevil and you watch
those those those the hallway seems some
of those automatic ya know for sure I
forget I'm watching a TV yeah when I'm
watching those it's like I feel like I'm
almost like a murse enough elderly yeah
there's something about this show that
like I'm definitely going to be
open-minded by the time I watch it as
much as I express concerns when I watch
trailers or whatever when it comes time
to sit down in the theater or a sedan at
home to watch it I'm going to be
open-minded and I because I want it to
be good I don't want it to fail I don't
want to be bad I think beat on paper
that sounds cool you got an Asian female
lead who's a badass action heroine what
we're getting I'm like I'm a little
intrigued but I'm not like that's going
to be a badass character I'm glad we got
an exclusive trailer just for her you
know know for sure I agree with you and
again not trying to compare to the other
shows but it is horrible Netflix show
but when we watch this is a standard
yeah yeah oh yeah when you and I like
watch daredevil trailers and we felt
Punisher where I got I want to see this
right now now no I mean that again where
you're coming from again I'm good like
you I'm going to have a very open mind
when this comes out I'm still looking
very forward to it because I'm a huge
fan of the Marvel Netflix shows they're
amazing I love going into this world
again you know it's good 12 13 hours it
gives you a good time to you know I get
get the progression its character and
get inside them so I mean I'm still very
intrigued by it I'm gonna have an open
mind but I mean this didn't do anything
to lower my standards earth like hiding
them yeah it's
okay I'm still looking forward to it
let's get it going all right i mean
we're gonna watch her regards yeah for
this yeah i mean we still so we saw
Vance [ __ ] stick for ya was at seven
percent but you know yeah I had to
really is it really this bad God you
know for sure calling wing versus a
lecture like the trailers for daredevil
they didn't really show a lecture up
fighting now that when the thing go is
when they showed a lecture in this
season two trailers a daredevil I was
like she seems cool like she's sexy
she's fiery he's got a different kind of
bad girl personality there's nothing
here in this trailer for a call i doing
that's like hook amico what makes her
such a standout unique kind of character
to bring onto a TV show and i'm really
hoping the show is better than the
trailers and what reviews the reso re i
want her to be a badass yeah we really
all we want this to succeed we do yeah
and i'm not shy to admit when I like
something that the majority are not like
yeah you know so yeah I would defend it
if I thought like I feel like this shows
miss understand I think if people saw
your Logan review you were like raving
about Laura x-23 and Taker like you like
those kind of a diecast characters so I
mean I'm with you know I'm I hope
calling and wing is up to the standards
of the lecture but again those are high
fan and I'm looking forward to seeing
the show and seeing if she dances
because it's weird to me how like I
think Claire who's like the main
connection let me water two shows she's
just a normal human being who has it of
strong so wrong man airing and
sacrifices and she's such an interesting
person who doesn't need to have fighting
skills it doesn't need to have powers
and yet i'm seeing colleen language
fighting skills and all this [ __ ] and
I'm like find Clara more interested you
know then again this is my first real
introduction in two minutes that's right
yeah we're basing three seasons off by
20 minutes of watching this we're just
going off the two minutes but ya know
again I'm looking forward to seeing this
character and then end again the
standards are high waves there's a lot
of interesting women in the Marvel
Malik's you
so she's got a lot of standard to live
up to for sure you know and we I haven't
done reviews of the other shows on
Netflix and you're never considering
actually like we're doing this show
maybe one because I feel like with these
marble shows you can review them one
episode I'm not sure not every show I
feel most shows I'm like you just got to
talk about the fees of this you can
review this one but marble shows like
there's usually nothing gather from one
episode of it definitely so yeah I mean
maybe we'll do if you guys want it will
do alright guys well you can subscribe
to the real rejects follow Andrew on the
movie source channel and he's also a
Gore 7-eleven on Twitter and Instagram
shout out to Andrews iron dick it glows
get huge and it causes mayhem some
during the week it's called Tony Stark
on the weekends it's called Danny R and
I like that thanks man we never joke
about your penis only on camera the
right time to do it right